[Music]
[Music]
the last time i regularly vlogged was my
video series documenting my phd studies
which finished in
2017 oh my god but as you'll see in this
video
not a huge amount has actually changed
from what i was up to back then
i'm going to show you what my life was
like today a wednesday
which is pretty representative of what i
get up to most of the time these days
there's gonna be a mix
of various projects but one in
particular
this evening i have my regular twitch
stream where i update people on my
progress on this project which is called
claude so i actually do need to get a
lot of good work done today there's
quite a few things i need to
fix but what is claude let me tell you
in song there once was an atmospheric
guy who's coding up
and made him cry a climate model he did
build
cla
[Music]
the model was built in python its
functionality near dawn his record was a
three-week run when
errors brought it low soon there'll be
convection
feedbacks and club formation one day
when the cone is done we'll
make our videos a problem in dimension
three
a problem at the boundary all these and
mormous solve it b
before we can use claude soon there'll
be convection
feedbacks and club formation one day
when the coding is done we'll
make our videos
as you would have ascertained from that
shanty based info dump claude is a
climate model that i've been writing in
python for quite a while and there's
basically two points to this project
the first is to make videos using claude
so to take the output of the model to
answer questions about atmospheric
physics to elucidate
points such as what would happen if the
earth spanned twice as fast what would
the atmosphere look like and we can put
that into the model very easily make a
video about the result however of course
there are plenty of climate models
already out there
the other aspect of chord is that it is
incredibly user friendly so it's written
in python not in fortran or
c or something that's a bit more
impenetrable and it's going to be
designed to be
open source and modular so that people
can download it themselves
and can play around with the contents
add bits take bits away
and so can suggest videos to make using
the model this morning i am basically
bug crunching so
two issues in particular plague claude
one is convection so stuff moving
vertically in the atmosphere and the
other one
is how claude deals with the poles
because latitude longitude coordinate
grids don't do so well really close to
the poles but i'll explain
why later because i actually need to
work
now bye
[Music]
now that was actually only about an
hour's worth of work this morning on
claude because i actually
need to leave the house
now the reason i have to leave the house
is because i'm actually on my way to
therapy which i've been doing for a
couple of weeks now and
i'm going to make a whole video about
the whole thing so i won't talk about it
now other than to say that therapy is
good this next bit's obviously quite
private though so i'll check in in like
an hour back at the house so i'm back at
home
now and i had a therapy session which
was good
and i've also had lunch which was good
and now
i can get back to work on claude and
actually explain a bit more what i'm
doing before the live stream this
evening which is in
[Music]
five and a half hours really i'd like to
fix two things but i think i'm gonna
have to accept that there is one thing
that i'm probably going to be able to
fix
today which is this discontinuity at the
boundary to briefly explain what i'm
doing the way that climate models work
is to evaluate the equations of how the
atmosphere behaves at
specific points on a grid you normally
define that grid in terms of latitude
and longitude lines so where latitude
and longitude lines
meet is a grid point and that's where
you evaluate your equations and stuff
like that
and basically what this program is doing
is iterating through
all of the grid points over the surface
of the earth and applying
um the equations of how the atmosphere
behaves your
radiation calculation so how much
sunlight reaches the surface how much
that heats up
uh the surface and then heats up the air
above it then you have your velocity
calculations so
how those changes in temperatures affect
how the winds flow
over the planet and at different heights
and then um
lastly the advection step of the
calculation which is basically
allowing wind to push stuff around so
if you have a hot spot uh that coincides
with
a strong wind that wind is going to
carry that
that heat that thermal energy to areas
that are cooler and
cause them to warm up and the hot area
to cool down slightly so it allows the
winds to actually flow and push
stuff around those calculations by the
way are actually separated out into a
different file so for example velocity
calculation here
um this is the equation basically that
you
use to describe how stuff moves in the
atmosphere and then there's another
library which has like all the basic
stuff like
gradients in it so my time today is
going to be spent going between these
three files the one that kind of
coordinates everything this basic one
uh this file that has the kind of
complicated
application of physics in it and then
this
file because the problem could be in any
one of these places and
i have five and a half hours to try and
pinpoint it is it time for a study
montage
i think it might be time for a studying
[Music]
montage
hi welcome to the inside of simon's head
as you'll notice there's quite a lot of
uh
empty space in here and nothing makes
sense you may be a bit confused at this
point because simon hasn't really
explained what he's doing so allow me to
step in
as simon mentioned before for the most
part in climate models you
want to calculate stuff on latitude
longitude grids because it's nice and
simple
this becomes a problem though when you
get close towards the pole and here's
why there are plenty of physical
equations where you need to know what's
happening horizontally so
how pressure a temperature changes as
you get further east or west or north or
south what we call a gradient or a
derivative
to work out the derivative you need to
know what the field whether that's
temperature say
is doing further east and further west
and then you basically take the
difference between those two and
divide by the distance between the
points and you've got yourself a
gradient
you know if it's getting colder as you
go towards the east or warmer as you're
going towards the east that's all
hunky-dory
if you're near the equator look what
happens when you get close to the poles
the distance between your grid points
gets smaller and smaller until by the
time you actually reach the pole
there's no distance between separate
grid points they're all in one place
at the pole there are lots of ways
around this but simon chose for claude
to use a polar plane method where
basically you slap
a flat plane on the north pole and on
the south pole and you calculate stuff
on that regular
cartesian grid rather than your latitude
longitude coordinates and then
once you've done the calculation you
just kind of merge the result from the
plane back into the latitude longitude
stuff
so you're effectively just approximating
the top of the earth as being
flat kind of it's a bit more complicated
than that simon believed that the
problem
was in how the calculations from the
flat planes were integrating
with the stuff on the latitude longitude
there was some mistake in terms of how
those calculations talk to each other
emerged
but as you're about to find out that's
not really the case
ah simon must be happy what's that
okay so something really exciting just
happened in the middle of our studying
montage
i was actually able to fix the issue
with the boundary and it turns out it
wasn't an issue with the boundary at all
so originally i believe that the problem
was in this function here the polar
planes function where you're calculating
the velocities on those two polar planes
and
there was some like misalignment of
coordinates it would probably be
something very small
and that was what was leading to those
discontinuities those
errors at the boundary but it turned out
that it wasn't in here
it was actually to do with an issue that
i thought i fixed last week
but because i'm a human peanut it turned
out i actually hadn't
the issue was to do with advection so
affection is basically
how air carries stuff places so
uh you know the advection of thermal
energy is to do with how
winds spread out hot air and they cool
down hot places and warm up
cold places but that's only one example
another
example of advection is actually in the
equations that describe how the
atmosphere
moves you actually get advection of
momentum
in terms of the equations you would
write it with this
term here because that's how you'd write
it out in equations you write out
uh your velocity u multiplied by the
gradient
in the x direction of your uh your youth
in this particular case in your east
west wind however as i learned last week
just because that's how you write it out
in equations doesn't mean that's the
right way to put it into
code you actually have to think about
how the computer is calculating this
stuff
and previously i stumbled on this idea
of basically picking the right
calculation of a derivative
if you do it wrong no matter what you do
your system is going to turn out to be
unstable and
i effectively without going into too
many details implemented that fix
last week and that made everything work
so much better it fixed a long-standing
issue and i was like great
we can now finally move forward and then
we run ran into this boundary issue
which i thought was something different
so this function here divergence for
scalar was the
function that i previously changed last
week that introduced this great fix
but i forgot that that's only when
you're advecting stuff like temperature
or moisture or whatever it may be
you also need to think about how you're
affecting velocity or momentum
and i basically this afternoon just
changed
how uh this uh this this function
calculates the change of velocity the
acceleration
and uh accounted for that same thing
so you have this same trick here with
the uh absolute values and it's the same
maths as up here
uh because it's the same phenomenon it's
still a vection and implementing that
fix has meant that the
code has suddenly become so much more
stable uh we finally punched through the
three-week barrier
for months and months and months i would
have dreamed of getting to a three-week
stable
simulation and we just blasted past it
it's looking so much cleaner i actually
haven't even been able to push this to
its limits i'm currently running the
model in the background
um and i'm waiting for it to explode
because
there will be some problem we're not
representing all physical systems we
still don't have convection in this
model for example
but and it's working it's a i fixed an
issue
the vlog is different i actually fixed
something this time
now however it is time for me to go
downstairs and cook pixel girl and i
some dinner
oh all right well it turns out that i'm
not doing that pixel girl is cooking
tonight because she felt like it so i've
just done the washing up instead i was
going to do a whole thing about the fact
that pixelgirl and i have been doing
veganuary and we're going to carry on
being vegan because it's been so easy
but
i guess i'll have to wait for a future
video for now though it's
10 to 7 so i need to get set up for the
stream i normally stream using my dslr
as my main camera which is why we're now
on phone mode uh basically just set up
the
live streaming setup so we've got
software going we've got the uh lighting
setup
the interactivity between uh twitch and
the lights in this room so when people
subscribe they flash different colors
that kind of thing
i know what i'm going to be talking
about and um basically i just need to
hit the go live button start playing
some music and then go live to like 150
people
and here we go live
hello everybody and welcome to the
stream
i'm filming this because i'm doing a
vlog everybody say hi and
oh there you go that was the integration
i was talking about okay everybody if
you want to make an appearance in the
vlog now is the
now is the time so yep this is basically
what it looks like when i am streaming
as i do every
wednesday and aren't my twitch chat
lovely right that's what that view looks
like now this is what it looks like when
i put my phone down
and i actually start streaming
so the stream went pretty well i think
uh
i spent the first half basically just
updating people on what i've been doing
off camera in terms of fixing the
momentum advection which is a huge step
forward and
before the stream i set claude running
and
uh it ran for just like a few minutes
shy
of 40 days which is huge double the
length of any previous run that we've
done i paint
most evenings now by the way basically
because i find it very relaxing
i really enjoy miniature painting as
i've talked about in
lots of places i stream me painting
my big project which is the hawaiian
orcs every friday on twitch and i have a
painting instagram
at 50 shades of space wolf grey in the
second half of the stream though i was
trying to
implement vertical advection uh
convection
and i naively thought that this would be
probably quite easy and
it wasn't turned out we could get it
working in most
of the model we could get it working on
the latitude longitude grid but when you
calculated it on the polar grid
it just didn't work so there's always
something
to look forward to next with this
project uh and once we get convection
working that's a really big step forward
because then it's a full
drive dynamical core and we can kind of
repackage it and we can make it
much much closer to something that can
be used for videos it's a really
exciting
time in the project let's go back up to
the office for a second though because
yes if you're interested in claude
as i said before you can download the
code on github
but what if you want to try and do
something like this
yourself
you can learn how to do it with
brilliant is an educational website and
app that gets you to learn by doing
solving problems and learning from your
mistakes remember it's okay to make them
claude is a project that requires
knowledge of the laws of thermodynamics
bam brilliant has you covered
it also requires knowledge of calculus
and finite difference methods
it also requires a lot of knowledge
about how to code
bam a whole course just introducing you
to python brilliant is ideal to support
your learning in the classroom or if
you've graduated from formal education
sharpening an old skill or even learning
a new one brilliance courses are
beautifully illustrated professionally
written
and a subscription comes with access to
thousands of practice problems ideal for
revision
you yes you do you want access to all of
that
and would you like 20 off your
subscription then head to brilliant.org
simon clark but hurry only the first 200
subscribers will get this great deal
thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
video and generally
being pretty awesome thank you for
watching the video i hope that you
enjoyed watching it as much as i enjoyed
making it
no the lockdown hasn't affected me at
all why do you ask let me know what you
thought of my return to vlogging
in the comments if this goes down well
then maybe i could do more as ever if
you're not already then please do
subscribe if you enjoyed this content to
see more like it and give it a like and
share it and all the things
that are going to bump engagement
engagement engagement feed the algorithm
feed the out and here's some recommended
viewing next
i've got to leave this up for the next
couple of seconds so i'm just going to
sit here um
just check my gamestop stocks
oh